toute la journée sans discontinuer les
raisins arrivent les blancs d'un côté de
l'autre les rouges et pour les équipes
dédiées au déchargement
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre et ça
veut vider en moins de trois minutes
le camion des fois ya plusieurs cols
blancs carrière c'est pour permettre aux
personnes ne repartir ici entre le
moment où le raisin est coupée et sa
mise en cuve
il ne doit pas s'écouler plus d'une
heure est à la table de tri c'est
l'exigence maximum d' enlever les
feuilles des grappins abîmée
rap un peu pourri une chance cette année
il n'y a rien à jeter
frédéric weber le maître de chai se
régale déjà scellé volnay kaïré c'est
une des parcelles historique de la
maison
c'est la première parcelle que la maison
de la famille bush a racheté en 1775
c'est vraiment super bien on a des
belles petites grappes assez compacte
leaf et les tanins quand on goûte les
pépins ses traits murs assez cassants et
à dire des arômes un peu de café ça va
être excellent
après un peu de travail quand même en
cuverie un site unique en son genre une
bois cuves inox
ici il y en a 2 182 toutes les
dimensions de quoi offrir à la récolte
de chaque parcelle une vinification à la
carte
en bon bourguignon on aime bien aussi
poussé paraît qu'on aime
même sur un même terroir on aime bien
séparer les vieilles vie des jeunes
vignes la partie du oda partie du bas
parce que l'expression se fait pas de la
même manière la dates de vendanges ont
changé donc on a besoin de cette
précision pour véritablement exprimé
chaque terroir comme il se doit un
impératif de qualité qui ne risque pas
de stresser frédéric webber cette année
sur les 120 hectares du domaine même si
les rendements sont faibles
les raisins sont superbes les vendanges
dans la plus ancienne maison
bourguignonne devrait durer 15 jours